16:15 is his war zone rated currently 68
participants gladiators out of 150
average rating 1803 time position
handicapped 30 minutes of silly chess a
lot of silly chest goes on in these hang
on hang on hang on oh this is the one
type of position I didn't want to start
out with
I need my B puns give me the bee puns
wait a second
fishing poles chop it up chop it up did
I play this guy before something is
telling me I might have played them
before 95 actually give me this chase
that night away grab the bishop
actually there's bishop check let's get
out of that take my bishop no take the
boy take um that was a free piece take
the free pieces what's the matter with
you take the free pieces if they're
there you better to start taking the
free pieces Oh scary tone scary town oh
we got mates tricky mates grab the rook
that's a mate back to tournament land
back to the standings two one one bunch
of zeros here we go
double up I'm playing against Carlsen
wait you just choked on my granola bar
that one went down the wrong pipe I
meant to say I forgot that I'm playing
like without a queen night where's my
umm where is my queen night he's that
Queen night this is gonna be dangerous
this is gonna be dangerous territory
here
okay c6 c6 get the light squared Bishop
off the board oh here we go
hit the Queen I'm not sure what that
does exactly
here we go let's do this okay hang on
Bishop Bishop Bishop hit the Queen grab
a night flight square flight square move
Knight not that one I want the other one
room okay what's the time situation time
time time time time I'm on the Queen I'm
on the Queen here here we go got the
material back no no I'm still actually
down upon but I have time time is a big
issue isn't it it's a big issue give a
check go to 83 hang on hang on hang on
let's play defense defense defense
defense what is my knight doing ah
nothing
he's not doing anything exciting let's
go each pawn attack do something H pawn
do something break it up break it up get
the h2 pond I'm coming for you a ch2 h2
with checker ooh ski back to tournament
six five three a bunch of two's okay
here we go
no no no Bishop pawns for you okay I got
that e5 move in I got the e5 move in and
maybe I could get a quick strike against
f7 I need to get rid of that light
square bishop if I'm gonna have any
chance of breaking down the black
structure let's see let's see if we can
make this happen
Bishop takes Bishop is on since the
knight is pinned grab the night and then
the bishop and in between it and in
between er uh Inbetweeners more
Inbetweeners
it's scary oh if I move my bishop
there's the problems let's avoid the
problems get out of the checks get out
of the tricks Oh more tricks here oh man
this is dangerous this is dangerous
territory
it's a dangerous territory okay why am I
getting 2d6 so easily Queen to f6 okay
they're not having anything they're not
having anything to do with that what's
the time situation what's the time
situation Queen c7 oh wait a second wait
a second Trix Trix Trix Trix right here
looking for mates pawn push pawn push
what do you do in response to pawn push
let's come back here guard the seventh
and I need a flight square for my King
that would be nice get the flight
squares in there you know oh that's made
that's made I shoulda done that sooner
back to tournament twelve eleven ten
twelve eleven ten here here we go here
we go here here we go here we go what's
going on pair me up here let's go
DOM Doritos no I don't get any Bishop
pawns I'd rather actually play down a
knight then give me my bishop pawns
I'll take those guys away from me and
I'm once again not playing um why am I
not doing the crouching oh I don't have
I have to get the the bee puns in there
no no no no let's do this hit it hit a
queen around hit the Queen around a
little bit
queen bee for is that gonna be annoying
let's do this okay let's get this in
here we go
rook here if the log is there it's an
open file isn't it oh okay now this is
going on okay h7 hang on to this Bishop
he's a good guy
you're gonna want to keep that one
around 94 94 connect my rooks not so
fast not so fast this is a scary night
this is a very very scary night let's do
this I'm on a 7
a three-name the squares right name
those squares right let's do this and
play this or something no there's Forks
what do I do
don't push this pawn push this pawn the
c6 would be hit oh I guess I have to go
for this I guess I don't want to take
that knife because then there's
connected pawns that looks a little
weird but I'm gonna do it I mean how I'm
gonna do that one anyhow let's come back
here and how much time why'd I do that
what am i doing I don't have any moves
I gotta do an in-betweener another
in-betweener
an in-betweener an in-betweener that's
code for
zooks one check time burners need some
time burners and that's not a good time
burner or maybe it is pawn push okay I
got behind it just didn't make it time
time burners time burners where the time
burners
well back to tournament they don't have
time
23:20 who's this guy Leo Leon this is
the leader this is the leader of the
pack right here
the cesar millan of the thunderhorse
right here pack leader
let's take I'm not sure why take with
the pun okay it's a little bit scary
over here Oh
Quino it was a little scary Queen h4
would have been would have been tough to
deal with
and now I'm gonna try this is this
working it's working isn't it it's
definitely working pins pins pins
everywhere let's do this first vacate
that's square I don't know there's a
queen check and they're out of pins oh
it's very scary
grab a rook oh oh there's gonna be made
let's do this oh man Queen f1 and stuff
like that you
know what's going on give a check means
some time burners time burners mates on
e7 maybe one day take a pie and hope for
the best
that's how you could do at this point
take a pun and hope for the best
let's come over here 87 they must be
scared uh oh they must be scared Czechs
ah I'm scared defend defend Oh Oh Queen
trade I don't want it
am I getting mated oh the girls ok
what's good I just hit that reside
button you idiot you idiot why'd you
drop your queen don't drop your queen
ever like that again oh what's the
matter with you
that stupid move that stupid pawn push I
shouldn't have done that
ah so much for the Queen Knight could
say goodbye to the Queen Knight and why
didn't I not okay that's what I meant to
do you think it's easy you think it's
easy it's not easy
let's go H pawn do something for team
Black team black light squares get light
squares going somehow get some attack
here here we go Castle queenside let's
try got a try open things up alright not
really the best way to do that oh this
night is gonna be a killer he's gonna be
a killer let's do this
and Knight right here he wants to get to
g4 my opponent is having none of it none
of it let's break down this light
structure although there's a killer for
coming up I'm gonna have to deal with it
I'm still gonna try and deal with it
okay I'm still gonna try and deal with
it
oh they should have just landed a deadly
deadly deadly fork right there okay they
missed the deadly fork okay here we go
light squares a big issue here my queen
is gonna be turned into the you know
killer move killer move white squares
must be
scared the king has to run he's gonna
pack up and run check grab the Queen and
there's no defense the new queen is
going to be on the scene a new clean on
the scene grab a knight first and then
push to promotion check back to
tournament can I recover from this 33
there's still hope don't give up so
easily here even though you're down to
Queen rook mating bishops
Oh quick resigner that's what I need
boom just like that just like that okay
okay here we go
and now it's party time is it party time
here okay
h 6 g 6 H 6 g 6 Bishop g7 we've seen it
before if you've been at one of these
thunderhorse tournaments observing away
o before this that happened before and I
thought you know maybe I should take the
night and then play d5 but I'll run with
this this is a brutal diagonal a brutal
diagonal are you gonna take my knight
now ok and now maybe I just want to get
my pieces over in this direction on f5
and g6
@ v g6 push the knight around push up
again and then get my dark square Bishop
on this diagonal ok hitting this pawn
and maybe maybe I okay let's do this
oh that's scary I want to move my knight
there very soon very very soon
Queen trade and have to go for it let me
take here first and then take here and
then what are my bees is doing that
night is gonna be a brutal piece a
brutal piece here c5 maybe I gotta get
out of that my knight is dead
this guy is dead so I'm just gonna have
to deal with that pawn push maybe pawn
push pin the knight pin that night get
out of this
oh okay let me take that I'm not quite
okay I got this
oh but that ponds gonna push oh man ah
this is bad this is really really bad
now I can't do that this is just push
your pond that's all they have to do is
push their pond that's all they still
have to do right or take my bishop pick
your favorite pick your favorite both
they're winning oh it's very scary I'm
gonna take this with check Oh how timely
oh wait I don't have any time
okay back to chairman up they're neck
and neck here 50 for each 54 54 42 we're
not even halfway there
hang tight back to tournament quick
resigner they were fear in my queen
night in that one they were feared the
Phantom queen night okay
Oh how do you like that to start how do
you like that Wow what's this the
al-qaeda's defense
oh man that Queen age 5 move is gonna
kill me really soon really soon it's
gonna kill me I got the F file though
I'm gonna make it happen with the f5
grab a knight and then see for this is
working no it's not I'm glad I didn't do
that
Bishop d5 lights out that would have
been lights out come here for a 5 ok
Queen takes d5 34 I mean grab that
Bishop just kill the bishop get my
knight doing something else okay grab
the bishop mmm let's do this
what's my night - nothing do something F
for incoming F for with tempo now guard
against c5 now let's do this they're not
threatening that actually maybe I do
want to still do this stop the c5 move
and let's go no let's go yes right here
double up double up and then I can
recapture on this square and
everything's defended hopefully 21
seconds not a lot of time
defend defend defend the knight is a
tricky piece give checks now what am i
doing move move your pieces check
they're gonna give check come back here
I need to pin the bishop and then just
come back here they'll probably defend
oh they must be scared checks I'm gonna
pin okay hang on
I need the Queen's on the board I need
those Queens on the board let's come
back here I'm gonna defend that give a
check come back here give a check and
come back here that's the name of the
game give a check and then come back
here check come back here
oh they caved in I got a two-to-one
majority you know what that means you
got to move quick that's what it means
Ron King gobble him up oh they were
trying to be sneaky
I could be sneaky too sneaky sneaky go
quick grab a pun push your pun
stepladder batched 87 256 okay here we
go
they do not like giving me the bishop
puns No
there will be no bishop pawns for you in
these tournaments ah man what did I do
to my dark square bishop let's go Bishop
d3 castle F file F file is officially
stopped it stopped there will be nothing
going on on the F file chase that night
away grab here give a check actually the
queen is not on the right diagonal to
give a check it's not the dark square
bishop from doing anything exciting my
dark square bishop also needs to do
something soon soon and fast here bishop
II won coming up oh that Bishop is there
to stay he's not going anywhere fast
he's not going anywhere let's get rid of
him no I can't get rid of him I have
pressure on this pawn though here we go
Bishop b5 Oh dark squares dark squares
be very fearful
got a breakdown this bishop breakdown
this Bishop f6 f6 h 4o knight check a
deadly night check Knight f6 oh man Oh
Queen h6 and then run away burn some
time they're gonna kick my queen away
kicked away my queen wants to come over
here now she wants to come over here and
this rook wants to play and they're not
okay I could play now let's break this
open g5 maybe one day g5 one day g5 it
is not so fast the Queen could take that
pawn maybe eight seconds eight seconds
they got o killer that's a killer it's a
killer Oh the Queen's the Queen's dead
give a check get g5 another check just
move they don't have time move the
knight back to tournament 186 68 okay
here we go
what's the clock like okay there's about
12 minutes 12 minutes here and here we
go this guy is I'm not I haven't even
okay let's try this I'm on the rook and
f7 it's just D 5 D 5 and everything is
ok but what about a 5 breaking up the
dark square pawns push your pond or take
my pond push your pond or take my pond
f7 f7 go g4 launch the G pun push the H
pun and in-betweener
it's an in-betweener uh-oh uh-oh there
might be big trouble for my opponent
already imagine that g3 h4 get ready
g3 h4 no I did the wrong order ok now I
have it but Knight right here is brutal
isn't it is that a brutal move Bishop
takes here first let's do that
and then oh man no let's do it the pond
now why did I do what the pun I was
stupid
okay let's come back home for just a
minute just a hair just a second
get that night out of their trade Queens
and I have oh well it's a rook versus
two minor pieces right reverses two
minor pieces I'll just have to try to
work with that one upon an f2 is down
he's down for the count
let's get my bishop out King e7 rook d8
here we go Knight f5 okay rooks out open
files what else what else rook to d4 oh
that's a good move that's a good move
yeah that's a good move
that night is gonna be awesome on that
square I'm gonna let my rook die okay
actually I was just gonna play that move
if they did that and now they're in a
pin I want to get rid of this okay now
the knight is dead time what's the time
situation is this a one King and pawn
endgame I don't know about that let's
hang on to that rook grab here if they
push push here get this epon rolling get
it rolling here and then give some
checks check and push up on and then do
what get my king up give some more
checks on the gh files they don't have
time capri move that check over here
back to term at the downtime 120 96 nine
minutes and change nine minutes in
change okay what to do when you're down
a Queen rook what to do when you're down
a queen rook here
what does my Oh what's going on with the
Queen what is she up to here what is the
Queen up to Wow was that a mouse slipper
that might have been a Mouse slipper
Queen G for maybe was intended or
they're doing are they're making on
purposes was that an on purpose or a
mouse lip okay
the night is hit it's looking pretty
good
it's looking pretty good I have still
lead in the tournament about 20 points
about 20 points and let's just get
pieces out and get the Queen rolling
grab a knight push up on grab a Knight
e4 d4 Knight f3 you name it anything
anything at this point material edge
very significant one tempo gainer go
with the tempo gainer queen d3 okay
I thought vision before maybe but
they're just sacking everything it seems
sacking everything right on the rim
right on the rim grab a pond give check
and then look for mate next check mate
check and then main what else down on
time any move any move back to
tournament 140 103 uh-oh uh-oh 140 103
no Queen night for you
no Queen night and stop Bishop b5 check
here we go get on this diagonal before
it's opened up for them and maybe just
launched the Jeep on launched the Jeep
on and before I play g4 I want to play
Knight on g6 okay maybe get the G file
working G file working somehow and okay
let's do this
where's that bishop gonna go okay
queenside castle pawn push in the center
let's try it maybe getting in a fork and
maybe even c5 something with c5 they
might be
d5 though and what do i do then that's a
fork got the piece back I get a piece
back okay
the pieces back and there is Bishop
check there's maybe some issues on the
edge file gonna take this or what's
going on with that move it's a free rook
was missed I guess that was a missed
move that was a missed move and this
right here is the only thing I need to
be cautious of Oh oh-ho wait a second
wait a second it's a little scary or
maybe even a lot scary okay let's do
this there was Knight check if I played
my knight there or my King there and I
have this though I have this resource
it's a good resource Knight here next
even if they take my rope there's a fork
on f3 or that simplified and I'm up that
rook f3 it's coming back what am i doing
let's come back here there's rook check
so let me just come back there's nothing
here let's give a check get that night
out of there the Knights gun then
there's nothing okay let's come all the
way back just defend defend give checks
how much time they are out of time back
to tournament 160 123 120 here we go 5
minutes and change 5 minutes and change
here so what do you do what do you do
what do you do what you do III 9282 h3
g4 we've seen this before seen it before
coming up it can happen
real soon really really soon okay they
have that defended g4 idea lemon support
to that but maybe I'll insist on getting
it in here we go h4 gh4 g5 h 4 g5 coming
up pawn push pawn push would be good my
Knights unprotected
but the files opened up now to opened up
and I could take here but I want to get
to the H file soon H file can it happen
here make it one make it one tricks
let's take care get my LightSquared
Bishop doing something do something here
Bishop e2 to h5 o that's pretty scary
let's come over here I don't want to
take this and open up the diagonal 33
seconds they have night here is actually
losing maybe King will go to f7 go to f7
f7 yes give me that night no no no no no
what did a second Trix Queen takes
Knight Bishop to g4 let's not and say we
did get rid of that night get rid of
that night and then give check out h7
rip to f1 next maybe here we go give a
check here and then a check here and
then mate coming up actually right this
is me lights out lights out bishop
blocks g7 leading to mate on g6 Oh why'd
I do that
oh this is mate still though kind of are
close to it I get a ruck out of it back
to tournament they're down on time
tourney and change 180 140 oh that's a
mountain to climb I think 40 points to
get it's three minutes to do it if I
could get this one in I think it's
official first place confetti looking
for the first place confetti here
Bishop b7 and okay okay okay h6 g6
Bishop g7 close keep it closed I don't
want to welcome exchanges when I am down
material so g5 night g6 bishop or Knight
to f4 and bishops gonna be coming back
to c8 since this diagonal shut down
let's get here right now and capture
like this I want the G file I could have
also consider getting the EEP
or the e5 square for my bishop keep that
night away and then get my queen doing
something good
get my queen doing something good and my
rep might as well play here soon or
maybe Bishop here looking for a pawn
push maybe I should have pushed my pawn
first I'll do it right now I'm on the
rook I'm on the rook let me get
something out of it
grab the rope and then rook to g8 Bishop
takes h3 Bishop takes h3 and let's do
this and then I know I should just
played King up King up double rooks
there we go there we go double the rooks
double the rocks double the rooks and
then take on g7 or take on h3 some
combination of the two
something's happening okay this is
falling and we're still even sort of
with the time get rid of this Knight I
can't get rid of that night actually
it's hang on I want to do that pawn push
pawn push I don't want to trade Queens
Queen takes I have this it's a blunder
okay break it down break down the jeep
on here
no Queen trade Oh pins pins everywhere
take upon take upon give a check grab
another pond look for me there's Bishop
here those Knights are on pretty nice
there let's get rid of one of them pawn
push takes I gotta watch out for
discovered tricks discover tricks take
run away scared
grab that beep on how much time enough
time to do it
check come here even if it's wrong even
if it's wrong look for me that's close
to me right here's close to make back
determines a 4/4 9 time 201 76 35 34 33
this is it
I got a try for a quick win maybe get
one more in extend the lead fantasy-like
variation - a queen
- the Queen night fantasy variation of
the Carol is that what we call it castle
let's go let's go here okay can I get
the Queen to h5 just take the night
maybe if it goes there
take the night clean h5 give it a shot
just move King to f8 actually pawn
pushes there the bishops guarding the
rook first place confetti its first
place confetti there it is purple green
blue all that fun stuff let me close out
ah good games all